recruiting product the thing called the
product tear down they take a product
they'll get their product owners product
managers developers designers they'll
get them around the table and they'll
tear down the product in terms of right
what are all the holes in it and what
could we do differently we should have
done that because there was a couple of
points in the first year where we were
cutting through but we definitely could
have cut through a bit better if we'd
have looked at our own sort of blind
spots yeah this is a fine line isn't
there between self-belief and that
arrogance in terms of there are other
ways you can do things I think it would
have had a bit more of a teardown
mentality yeah it gives you feedback for
it